MALE SPEAKER: OK.
Our third panel is going to be
about testing and tooling.
And our moderator is
Todd Anglin, who's
executive VP at Telerik.
They produce tools
for developers
and developer teams.
You might know him best for
Kendo UI, and I've seen him.
So take it away, Todd.
TODD ANGLIN: Great.
So I am strictly the time
keeper up here.
Telerik obviously creates a lot
of tools, but I think our
panel, which is quite diverse
today has the full
perspective.
We've got about six questions
total in the moderating queue.
So we'll probably start there
to kick it off, but I
definitely want to make this
as interactive as possible.
I know we're starting to stand
between you guys and alcohol,
which is always a great
place to be.
So to kick it off, I will
let the panel introduce
themselves.
I was introduced Todd Anglin,
work with Telerik, you guys
known as Kendo UI, but I'll
let the panel introduce
themselves.
PAVEL FELDMAN: I'm Peter
Beverl-- oh no.
Sorry.
I'm Pavel Feldman, software
engineer working on Chrome
Developer Tools.
YEHUDA KATZ: Hey, I'm Yehuda.
I work on Ember mostly these
days I've historically worked
on jQuery and Rails.
ANTON KOVALYOV: Hey,
I'm Anton Kovalyov.
I work at Mozilla.
We make a web browser and a
mobile operating system.
And I work on Firefox developer
tools there.
JONATHAN LIPPS: I'm Jonathan
Lipps, and I
work at Sauce Labs.
And this year, I've been working
on open source project
for mobile automation
called Appium.
BRIAN LEROUX: Hi.
I'm Brian.
I work on PhoneGap and
Cordova and a thing
called Topcoat at Adobe.
TODD ANGLIN: Very good.
So very diverse panel.
Guys, kick it off.
First question here,
it's from Rob.
And the question is basically
asking how does Google test
its mobile products.
So what are the things you use
to test your mobile products?
But to make a bit more generic,
I think we can just
open it up.
How do you test your mobile
products today?
What are the techniques you
use to ensure that you're
delivering good mobile
experience?
So we'll kick it off linear and
start here with Google.
PAVEL FELDMAN: OK.
so I'm working on Chrome, not
really any mobile app or web
for Chrome.
But we use the same tooling for
testing Chrome aggressions
as our apps are using, and
that's telemetry, which
applies pretty much
to everything
WebGet Chrome based.
It has been mentioned earlier.
Check out it on the
Chromium web site.
There's documentation for it.
It's a lightweight script
framework with a friendly
Python framework front end.
It's based on remove
debugging prodigal.
You can automate things there,
simple automations,
navigations, scrolling.
And you can capture all of the
data that Chrome dev tools can
capture, all of those pages and
all of those scenarios.
So you get full-fledged timeline
there, and everything
is Jason based.
You can analyze this data.
And we are internally building
regression charts for that, a
lot of birth data for each of
the commits, each of the
builds we see what has
happened there.
And we can go back
and [INAUDIBLE].
So that's pretty simple.
And that's what we expect
everybody to do.
YEHUDA KATZ: Hey.
So I pretty much use your
product for testing.
I don't have a huge array
of physical devices and
little start up.
So I definitely like the test as
many pieces of hardware as
I can, and you guys have
a really good group.
And if I was much bigger, I
would want to have more
devices to test with
but sadly enough.
ANTON KOVALYOV: So I work on
Firefox for desktops, so I
don't really work on actual
mobile web apps.
But the closest we have, I
guess, to the testing mobile
web apps would be Firefox apps,
and as far as I know we
have another Mozilla here.
So if I'm saying something
stupid, correct me.
I think we use the same
framework as our own written
framework as we use for Firefox
or desktop, which
basically simulates all the
events you can have.
And as all testing frameworks
out there, no offense to any
framework writers, it
could be way better.
And its partial our job as
well as Firefox Developer
Tools engineers to
make it better.
So far it's getting there.
But really, unfortunately, I
don't have a better answer
what we use for actual testing
our mobile web apps, if
Mozilla has any mobile
web apps.
JONATHAN LIPPS: That's it?
ANTON KOVALYOV: No.
TODD ANGLIN: This is a
highly-qualified panel.
JONATHAN LIPPS: Yeah.
So at Sauce, we use this project
called Appium, which
if any of you guys have done
testing of your web apps, you
might have used Selenium.
Appium uses the same protocol,
and it can test the native
mode of your applications, or
native Android, or native iOS
applications.
It can also test if you have a
mobile web app, you can use
the native web application,
Safari, and Chrome, and also
test kind of the hybrid views
of each of those.
So you kind of get all of the
levels of your application
especially if you have a hybrid
application, that's
pretty hard to do.
So it works pretty well.
BRIAN LEROUX: OK.
So on the PhoneGap project, we
built a big ass wall, and we
stuck a shit load of phones to
it, and we wired all those
phones up to a Mac mini.
And every time a commit lands
inside of Apache Cordova,
which is the open source or
the project, we compile
PhoneGap, we load it with the
web app that has a bunch of
Jasmine tests.
Some of the tests are in queue
unit, but that's just
historical.
And then we post those
results of those
tests back to a couch.
And you could see this stuff,
I think it's like at
test.cordova.io.
And so you have to test
on real devices.
You can't get around that.
Devices have sensors, and you
can test for things like, say
is there an accelerometer, but
you can't actually test the
accelerometer data coming
through unless you build a
robot, which we're talking
about with Sauce.
So we're doing that.
It's an open source project.
It's called medic.
If you're interested in
automating, pushing native
apps to phones, and get
test results, we
can talk about later.
There's another project at Adobe
call Topcoat, which is
CSS project, and we're using
telemetry from Chrome to get
the data out of that.
So we have a custom build, at
Chrome, CF, and when we land a
commit into our CSS, we add that
to a page, and then we
load it, and then we add like
200 elements to a page.
And we load that, and
we scrolled it.
And we measure load time,
layout, and frames per second.
And so we know that in each
commit that the CSS is
actually getting faster
and faster.
And all that's open
source too.
It's at Topcoat organization
inside of GitHub.
ANTON KOVALYOV: I have
a [INAUDIBLE]
a question or more
like rambling.
So I feel like there's a notion
in the mobile net world
where you have to test
on the actual device.
And this is true.
You have to.
You can get away from that,
but I don't know if we're
actually working so it's
reducing the amount of testing
we need to do on actual
hardware, because attaching a
shit load of phones to the wall
doesn't scale when you
have 200 engineers.
Because then you have hundreds
of commits per day, every
commit launches a phone and then
you wait for the test to
be done in like what,
2 hours, 10 hours.
So shouldn't we like I said
tell to the developers, I
guess, work on reducing
the hardware
dependency or adding--
and I'm just throwing out
ideas because I haven't
actually thought about that--
or adding better simulation
to devices, or even better
assimilation so the log grade
hardware to the hardware
limitations.
So that I could say, run this
test and then run this test
when you have only 2 megabytes
of memory left.
And so the question actually
mostly to you guys.
JONATHAN LIPPS: So I do think
that simulators and emulators
provide a good kind of
base-level testing, they're
actually advantages over using
real devices, things like
making sure that you have a
clean, stable environment.
But you're really only testing
the changes in your code
making it easier to run as
part of your continuous
integration on every commit.
Maybe you want to run your
full battery of mobile
functional test on emulators
because that's cheap and easy,
but you don't want to run
on all of the huge
matrix of real devices.
You want to do that when you're
ready to cut a release
or whatever and then have
a little bit more
confidence around it.
So I think you can view it as
kind of a two-phase process,
or you do more of the cheaper
resource, which is
emulators/simulators which you
can virtualize the shit out of
and then less of the more
expensive resource, which is
sticking devices on walls.
BRIAN LEROUX: Yeah, the device
wall does not scale.
That's true.
But you've got to do it.
So the simulator/emulator thing,
the only problem with
it is, you're in a virtualized
environment and then you're
probably on good hardware, with
good network, with lots
of memory, which is basically
what mobile isn't.
YEHUDA KATZ: I think Anton's
point was, hey, people who
make simulators, maybe you could
not have it emulate a
perfect environment.
BRIAN LEROUX: Yeah.
YEHUDA KATZ: Right?
I agree.
It would be nice.
I know the Book to Gecko
simulator, what was it called,
R2-- it was a terrible name.
What was it called R2D2,
V2G or something crazy?
Anyways the Firefox OS simulator
is kind of cool
because it is that and it
is the environment.
Whereas like iOS and everything
is not quite the
real thing.
And the other problem is like
all these sensors like, I
guess we can just chuck fake
data at it, hope that it's
doing the right thing.
But it's a complicated
problem for sure.
There's another way to test and
that's just release often.
That's a bad, bad solution.
PAVEL FELDMAN: There's
another aspect to it.
Everything we're talking about
today has this performance
aspect, so everything
is performance when
we're talking testing.
Testing is testing, and
testing as a group
performance.
And the latter is
important to us.
And the later is challenging
to emulate or simulate.
We've been doing something
profiling for Intel and ARM.
And the pictures that
we were having were
just radically different.
And hardware assimilated stuff
isn't entirely different.
So if you're interested in the
end result and the interest in
not regressing the end result
on the device, as of today,
there's no other way other
than getting it to the
hardware and testing it there.
BRIAN LEROUX: Like one other
thing to throw out there for
people, like measuring is like
super important because then
that's how you get to a better
result ultimately.
But the problem with all this
is that it requires a lot of
boilerplate set up that
developers just
do not want to do.
When you're writing code, you
don't want to go put on your
profiler hat and start
profiling.
You want to write code, right?
And ideally, you're notified
that hay, something just got
slower, fix that.
Instead of finding out after you
deploy out of context in a
context switching.
So there's a definite need for
better tools that happen
during authoring time.
PAVEL FELDMAN: I think
we'll get there.
Telemetry is a perfect first
step there, because USS
performance as your app
runs, you want to
add the script running.
WebDriver is just not evolving
fast enough to capture all
that data, so telemetry is kind
of a fast and hackier way
for WebDriver plus the
instrumentation.
And running profilers, and
raising flags, doing all that,
that will all come.
We're just only starting
there.
YEHUDA KATZ: So I have an
honest question about
profilers in general, which
is do people who write the
profilers actually, is there
like any user testing at all?
And I don't mean like, get your
grandmother, but I mean
like, get me to sit in front of
it and look at me trying to
use a heap profile dump.
Like, if you just watched me
for 10 minutes, I think you
probably have 10 good ideas
on how to make it better.
I guess it's a question
for Pavel.
PAVEL FELDMAN: Yeah.
OK.
So memory profiling is hard.
And no matter what platform
you're in, be it Native or
Java or JavaScript,
historically, memory profiling
has been a separate task that
you were forced to do.
You didn't want to do that.
Just because you are always
forced to do it because you're
out of memory.
And you don't want to do it,
because it's is hard and
challenging.
Because memory heap is a graph
and it's really complex.
But I guess what you're talking
about is Chrome Dev
Tools UX for heap profiler.
We are making some good
improvements there.
Some of them are recently
demoed.
We are aware of certain
complexities there and certain
degree of education that you
need to gain the hard way
before you get a sense of it.
We threw out the garbage of the
UI and of the heap, we're
removing certain data, but you
shouldn't fool yourself.
It's a hard problem to tackle,
and it will remain hard.
Hopefully, we are trying to
make it simpler for you.
BRIAN LEROUX: You know, one
thing to throw on top of that,
this is something sort of like
we're ashamed of in the
Topcoat part of the reality,
we're using telemetry.
We love it.
It works really well.
It's a good way to get
a measurement and our
assumption, which is probably
not true, is if we're using
telemetry data, that means we're
using Chrome and that
means we're measuring Chrome.
And we figure if it's getting
faster in Chrome, it's
probably faster in
other places.
But that's an assumption.
And so we need these
APIs actually back
in the browser proper.
We need them in IEs.
YEHUDA KATZ: So a couple
of examples--
BRIAN LEROUX: Not calling out
IE specifically any more.
I probably should shut up.
YEHUDA KATZ: I could get
a little more concrete.
So a couple of examples on the
heap profiling thing, one of
them is, so heap profiling
basically tells you if you're
leaking memory.
It says like, hey, after running
a GC pass, we can see
that there's X amount
of memory.
But actually the thing that
sucks about garbage is not the
garbage that's left, it's
often just like you're
generating a ton of garbage
and it's causing jank.
And as far as I know none of the
heap profilers allow you
to say like, hey, I want you to
tell me what's on the heap
now, but don't run a GC first.
And this is not a very
complicated thing.
It literally means don't run the
GC first and then tell me
the same thing that you're
telling me already and use the
same differencing tools
to do that.
And I think there's things
like this that, I mean, I
wonder how the Chrome
team is--
surely the Chrome team and the
Firefox team occasionally run
its issues where they're writing
some self-hosted code
and they generate a
lot of garbage.
They want to know what
the garbage is.
I'm curious what they
are doing for
these types of problems.
PAVEL FELDMAN: So this
particular one, the underlying
implementation is that you
can visit all your
heap within the GCM.
That's the only way you
can visit your heap in
[INAUDIBLE].
You could work around it.
And I think this particular
thing just did not come up.
To answer your previous
question, our clients, the
biggest client that
we have is Gmail.
And all of the headache that
we were getting was Gmail.
And it was more than a gig of
RAM before they started using
it, and then it was like, back
and forth iterative process.
Gmail was improving, tools
were improving.
So in-house, we were working
like with large web apps where
memory matters most.
YEHUDA KATZ: so you were
worried more about
applications that had a lot of
persistent memory and less
about just like a bunch of
memory that got created like
during scrolling, let's say.
PAVEL FELDMAN: We're just
picking Gmail as the largest
like crazy app out there.
ANTON KOVALYOV: To answer this
question, so I run into these
issues when writing Firefox
front end code since it's all
JavaScript.
And what I do, I usually
cry myself to sleep.
Then I wake up and use our very
basic tools that we have
to kind of fix the problem.
So it's not the answer that we
have a solution for this.
My answer is that everything
pretty much sucks, but we're
working towards improving
that.
So Yehuda already gave us really
good feedback, but if
anyone else has feedback on
how the memory profiling,
what's in the garbage, and other
things could improve
your lives, that's
really helpful.
Because I used to be
a web developer.
Now I mostly work on the
platform for desktops, so I
don't do that much
web development.
So we need input from
the outside.
TODD ANGLIN: So I think that's
a fair point to transition
almost as a natural follow up.
I mean, I think we would all
agree dev tools and browsers
have come a long way in
a very short time.
But they're clearly not
done improving.
From your perspective, working
with them, really digging into
them, what are the things
we most need still
in browser dev tools?
And this can be Chrome or just
cross browsers in particular.
YEHUDA KATZ: Yeah.
Hey.
This is my topic.
So in my opinion, the dev tools
have come a long way,
and the biggest gaps in the
current dev tool story verses
like some native tools is
there's a very limited ability
for framework and library
developers to help the dev
tools present information
in a more useful way.
So let me give you
a simple example.
If you are writing--
a lot of the code that's inside
of Chrome is actually
written in JavaScript.
And for example, you might
imagine that for each forum,
native arrays is written
in JavaScript.
But of course, when you press
the down arrow to step into
your code, you don't actually
see the native code, you just
see your own code.
Because the browser has the
ability to say, I do not want
to show you this
internal code.
But as a framework author,
I don't actually have any
ability tell the browser like,
hey, unless the user really
wants to see this, they
shouldn't see this.
So you may have like a number of
frames that the user has to
step through that's
an abstraction.
And maybe sometimes they want
to see it, but 99% of the
time, they want to see
their own code.
There's other things like
ability to annotate a stack
tray so that if there's async
code you can basically
stitched together a bunch
of stack traces.
And this is information that I
have as a framework developer
because I'm the one doing
the deferral.
So I do a lot of crazy stuff
in Ember, but even simple
things like jQuery and Backbone
will benefit a lot.
And I think as far as I can
tell, there's basically been
essentially no work done on this
area when there's been a
lot of work done on
a lot of things.
So of course, it's possible to
say, well, this is a low
priority, but I think given the
amount of people that use
dev tools and use frameworks and
libraries, I think will be
very beneficial.
JONATHAN LIPPS: Yeah.
I think another thing that would
be pretty cool is better
cross platform dev tools so
each of the platforms has
their own somewhat good in some
cases set of dev tools.
But then you have to learn
something completely different.
And so if there was, I don't
know, maybe there are
standards in the works.
You seem really anxious to
talk about something.
But I mean, you could say the
same thing with the native
mobile layer, which we're not
really talking about too much
right now, but is also obviously
important right now
in history.
ANTON KOVALYOV: I'm very anxious
to talk about it
because people ask this question
a lot for Firefox
mostly since we're still
catching up obviously with
Chrome dev source.
So like, oh, why don't
you just do the
same debugging protocol?
Well, this is not going to
happen anytime soon mostly
because both Chrome and us and,
I don't know, whatever
Internet Explorer has, we all
want to iterate really fast,
and we have different
priorities.
For us, for example, I just
want to describe why the
standardization of their mobile
debugging protocols is
not happening right now.
For us, for example, the Firefox
is a priority, right?
So what we are working on, like
among other things, is
the ability to send files or
giant blobs over the protocol.
Giants multi megabyte and
encrypted-generated files is
also a priority for us.
I don't know if it's a
priority for Chrome.
And it might not as well
be, and it's cool.
But if we will start converging
the protocols and
doing any kind of synergization,
this will slow
everyone's down.
So the solution to this, I
think, and I ask my team
yesterday, so my team's solution
is to write a shim to
the protocol.
So when the time comes and we
want to use our protocol, our
developer tools for Chrome, for
example, we can write a
shim that will just make a
bridge between two protocols,
and then we can do that.
BRIAN LEROUX: So just quickly.
It is going to be standardized
TC-39.
And I know folks at Adobe are
trying to take the lead on
that, and yes, it's not going
to happen any time soon.
And I totally acknowledge
that.
But it's kind of ironic, I don't
often do this, but I'm
going to praise Java.
Java did this.
It has debugging as a part of
a language first class, and
JavaScript does not, and
hence, here we are.
And this is desperately needed
to have third-party tool
ecosystem that sits outside
of the browser.
Right now, it's almost a
browser differentiator.
PAVEL FELDMAN: I would second
though the standardization is
going to slow us down.
We don't want to evolve
as fast as Java.
We want to evolve
a bit faster.
And when we were on the
beginning of our journey,
there was a protocol.
There was scope, [INAUDIBLE],
and we didn't adopt it.
We came up with our own thing,
and our thinking was we need
to do it as fast as possible,
and as convenient ourselves as
possible, as close to the
underlying system as possible.
So you would see that our
network domain, for example,
is very much a WebGet
specific.
It has things like loader IDs,
resource IDs, which are not
used in Firefox, so the concepts
are different.
And of course, we were thinking
if it becomes a big
thing, we'll be standardizing,
but the further we are ahead
in the process, the more chances
that the protocol that
we implemented natively becomes
the de facto standard.
And I could understand the
willingness to do the same
thing again.
And we were also thinking that
changing adapters in the
protocols on the Jason or Wire
level will solve it.
Because debugging domain
is very conservative.
You just step through
stuff, and you
don't do anything fancy.
And once you stop doing anything
fancy, it starts to
differ from browser
to browser.
So we are still waiting for
a number of big players to
become clients of several
browsers to see that there is
a need for that, there is an
investment to it, and then it
will be a clear signal
that there is a
need for such a standard.
BRIAN LEROUX: Yeah.
I don't think one comes at the
expense of the other at all.
And just to like throw some
weight behind Yehuda's
comment, I think it's well
beyond time that we have
better instrumentation points to
the browser so that we can
see the framework start
providing better hooks.
Because the abstraction layer,
like nobody wants to step
through jQuery.
That's insane.
TODD ANGLIN: So we've answered
two questions.
We don't have a ton of time.
If we can move it forward.
MALE SPEAKER: We'll take
the final reply.
TODD ANGLIN: We'll take the
final reply on this then we'll
move on to--
YEHUDA KATZ: The final
reply it was, what do
you want from tools?
So whatever you want from tools,
please file the bugs.
We are bugs driven.
It's yourbug.com If you are a
framework author, please post
to all your framework clients
to start this bug, and we'll
have no other option
of implementing it.
TODD ANGLIN: There you go.
That's how you can
force your way.
Before we're forced into our
final count down, I want to
make sure we at least giving our
audience a chance to ask a
question directly.
So if there's anybody who has
a question in the space of
tools and tooling, I was told
there are a lot of questions.
Any questions here?
Here we go right here.
BEN DILTS: Ben Dilts
from Lucidchart.
One thing that's been a real
challenge for us over time is
trying to collect error
reports in production.
So like in the Closure Library,
there's something
about like an error collector
and it has very widely-varying
usefulness of data that comes
out of that based on what
browser, what version,
or what have you.
And it's almost impossible to
get a stack trace of where you
currently are because
you have like the
caller on the function.
But obviously, once you have
a circular reference.
Anyway so is there some master
plan for making that better,
because it's really terrible
right now.
ANTON KOVALYOV: I'll
start answering.
Everything is very sad.
So when I was working at Disqus,
we had this problem
where we wanted to send reports,
and everything was
really sad.
Now, I checked actually a couple
of weeks ago because a
friend of mine asked, and across
a browser, it's like
it's pretty good in
Chrome, think it's
kind of good in Firefox.
But when you get like cross
browser, it's really basic.
And unfortunately, this is not
what developer tools team can
fix at Firefox.
This is either DOM or language
design thing.
And with DOM, you have WebID
and then it starts to cry.
BRIAN LEROUX: What
about TowTruck?
ANTON KOVALYOV: Oh, our thing?
BRIAN LEROUX: Yeah.
You're thing.
ANTON KOVALYOV: Yeah,
it's pretty cool.
BRIAN LEROUX: Great.
ANTON KOVALYOV: So yeah, one
thing I want to say is that if
there is even more important for
mobile development because
there when you have an error on
the desktop, you're like,
oh, what are you using?
Are you using Firefox 21.
OK.
You'll launch our Firefox
[INAUDIBLE]
for use.
On mobile like, oh, we're using
this Firefox 900 Android--
I don't know what their version
is so I'm going to
have to use 2.4 or something,
something.
And then you cannot really
reproduce it.
So your best choice is to
collect data and save data to
the server all time.
It will only be grounded about
every sub trace and stuff.
And I was helping my friend
in Century to do it for
JavaScript, and that's
why I was really
anxious to answer that.
You should bug everyone you know
about the browser vendor
to fix that.
You should just not stop.
You should demand this, because
this is really Ember
for the web that we cannot send
the stack traces to the
server normally across
a browser.
So I'm just acknowledging.
YEHUDA KATZ: I also agree,
and I've raised this a
few times on TC-39.
And there is a low appetite
for standardizing stack
traces, but I think
this is a mistake.
So the issue to get past is
that when you standardize
stack traces, you are forcing
the VM authors into particular
pattern of how they have
to collect and
maintain their code.
And this is not a good excuse,
and I agree with Anton.
You should make sure that all
the browser vendors and VM
pointers that you know
know you don't
think it's a good excuse.
Like this is probably,
it's like a
first step of debugging.
It's like before print after
debugging, it's like give me a
stack trace.
And we don't even have
it on the browser.
And it is probably sufficient to
leave open a little bit of
wiggle room in terms
of what exactly you
are required to do.
But having some notion of like
some standardization here
would be very helpful.
Yes.
And people should ask.
TODD ANGLIN: So I've got the
five-minute warning, which
means that it's probably time to
take our 30-second answers.
So I hate to be repetitive to
the other panels here, but
there's not many better ways
to wrap up than to ask you
guys, with the perspectives
represented here both two
authors and consumers and
platforms, if we were back on
the stage a year from now, and
we're talking about tooling
and testing, either one given
the subject, what is the thing
you would hope is most changed
a year from now?
I mean, there's a lot of things
that need to be done.
We've been told it's
a very sad state of
affairs right now.
It's a very depressing panel.
But what is the thing you would
hope a year from now is
not depressing relative
to today?
We'll just run down the line.
PAVEL FELDMAN: There'd just
be better tooling.
TODD ANGLIN: That's
your job, right?
PAVEL FELDMAN: Right.
And we'll make that.
So imagine you're running
your app--
30 seconds, right?
You're running your app, and you
can go forward and back in
time explore everything,
everything that
was consuming time.
All of the causes fixed in live,
the replay thing, it
works faster, then make sure
that it does regress.
Just a miracle.
TODD ANGLIN: So that's
May 16, 2014.
And we've got a commitment
here.
All right.
YEHUDA KATZ: The answer I used
to say to this was some
browser, any browser, pause
on Stack Overflow.
Thankfully, Firefox does it.
Chrome, please pause
on Stack Overflows.
This is ridiculous.
But in all seriousness, what I
want, in general, is just more
ability as a library and
framework author to control
what it is that the tools are
showing to my users, because
having my code be essentially
treated as equivalent to their
code is really not a good
experience, and it is, I
think, beyond a small issue.
ANTON KOVALYOV: So understanding
in terms of
mobile tooling, I think it would
be really nice, and I
know both Chrome and Firefox
are working on that, is to
lower the barrier entry to
using the dev tools.
The fact that we require, like
Firefox requires web
developers to install Android
SDK and use ADB to connect to
Firefox to Android to debug
their god damn web application
is insanity.
There should be a Firefox add
on or something, Android
plug-in or Chrome plug-in that
says, OK, now, you can connect
your device.
Now, you're all good.
And we're actually
working on that.
Someone told me today that
Chrome is working on that.
So it's really good, and
hopefully, in a year or less,
we'll have a much lower barrier
of entry for web
developers to actually
use tools to
debug mobile web sites.
JONATHAN LIPPS: Taking a more
testing prospective, what I
want to see is you check code
for your iPhone application,
your Android application, and
your web application.
And to GitHub your continuous
integration pulls that down.
All three versions of the
application are built.
application are automatically
tested using the one, single
test suite, not three.
And then it's built, signed for
deployment, deployed to
your fleet of beta users, and
then given some standard
metric that you're tracking,
automatically deployed to your
app store to the web.
I think continuous deployment
integration for mobile is
awesome, and it's
not there yet.
BRIAN LEROUX: Fuck,
I'd love that.
Good luck.
So there's like two ways to
look at the whole problem.
Steve Souders has an awesome
article about how the mobile
web is getting faster.
It's like something--
I don't know.
I can remember.
It's a percentage faster.
But the problem is developers
are still writing bigger and
bigger web apps.
And the web apps themselves are
getting bigger, and so the
performance gains on sort of
the platform side are being
lost due to the weight.
So to me, I'd view very much
as a bit of a documentation
issue that we got to get in
front of developers and tell
them to start measuring their
stuff so they start actually
building improvements themselves
instead of just
loading a whole bunch of script
tags and large images,
they have to start thinking
[INAUDIBLE] side about how
they're going architect
their apps.
That's what I hope for.
TODD ANGLIN: Cool.
So on that note, thank
you, panel.